- The thing that the
left has done very,
very effectively
is claimed to have
a monopoly on morality
because it defines morality
in quite a narrow way itself.
It has to be essentially
rationally calculable.
But actually, if
you think about it,
a lot of what we actually
do that is moral,
is actually very
sentimental and habitual.
We didn't think about it.
We just do it because it's
the right thing to do.
And so if you are actually
taking principles like freedom
and inequality,
well actually you can
destroy the family
with those principles.
You know, you don't owe
anything to your parents
and you can't say that your
your father is superior
to you because
that's not equality.
And so you're not
bound by being...
You didn't choose
your parents but...
And so by the principles
of freedom, equality,
you can be unbound
from your own family.
And like children can
have no responsibility
to not only their parents,
but their own country and
to anything like that.
It's like, God, this is
actually quite horrific.
(relaxed music)
- Do I call you Carl or do
I call you Sargon of Akkad
now that we are
officially sitting down
once again after many years?
- I think Carl will do.
- Carl will do?
- Carl will do.
- Alright, there is a lot I
want to talk about with you.
And I said to you right
before we started of all weeks
for you to be in America,
'cause you live across the pond,
you came the very week
that we're opening up
this studio to in-person guests.
And for people who do not know,
who haven't been with
me since the beginning
of the beginning, when I
was waking up to the left.
What's going on with the left?
Why are we calling
everybody racist?
No one's actually
acting liberally.
- Yeah.
- The Sargon of Akkad story.
Everybody online, all
the commenters said,
"Dave, you gotta watch
this guy Sargon of Akaad."
I don't know that your
face was even in the videos
at that time.
But everybody said,
"You gotta watch Sargon
of Akaad (indistinct)."
I started watching your
videos and I'm going,
"Wow, this guy's a liberal
and he makes sense."
And then eventually
we started talking.
You had me on your show,
and in some ways
the rest is history.
So I think I've done it once
or twice over the years,
but I give you serious cred
for getting me here today
because you were one of
the first in that way.
So give the people like the
two-minute bio about you
first and then we'll
get into the politics
and the fighting
and the craziness
and the state of the
world and the rest of it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And welcome to the
free state of Florida.
- It's beautiful.
It's so much nicer
than California.
(Dave laughing)
There's greenery around, right.
I'm from England, so if I'm
not surrounded by greenery
I get a bit weird and edgy.
And California is just this
brown blasted hellscape of dirt,
whereas Florida, it's
luscious, genuinely luscious.
- You're speaking my language.
- It's crazy 'cause I was
the same though, in, for me,
it happened in about 2012,
2013, where I was just,
I wasn't even like a hard
liberal, I was just like, well,
no, I'm a liberal person
and I believe in, you know,
basic liberal ideals,
which most of us really do.
Even even the quite
conservative people will say,
"Well actually, yeah, I mean
obviously I want rule of law,
freedom of speech
and property rights
and all these sorts
of things, right"
Fairly basic stuff.
So it's not stuff we had
to think about too often.
And then we had this very
aggressive and what I now,
after the fact have
learned is just essentially
an open communist insurrection
within liberalism.
And at the time they
weren't publicly like that.
You know, it's actually
been quite far on
that you've got Hasan
Piker being like,
"Yes, I'm a communist.
Here's my red flag,"
you know, behind him.
Which is, you know,
okay, fair enough.
At least the mask's off, right?
Because before they would
say, "I'm a liberal,
but everything around
you is racist and we need
to redistribute all the wealth."
- Right, right, right.
- Seize all the property.
I'm like, that's not
very liberal though.
- Oh, well that's
refreshing to hear
that they're giving up
the mantle of liberalism.
That would be nice.
Because they're actually
the most illiberal people
on the planet.
- Of course, and
they know it as well.
That's the thing.
They are well aware
that they're just like,
"Right, okay, what
can we do to kind
of explode liberalism
from the inside?
And, honestly, they've
done a good job of it.
- But wait, before we get
to them and everything else.
What, so it's 2011, 2012,
you're saying, you know,
"I'm just kind of a
liberal, I'm a liberal guy."
But now you're doing
some stuff on YouTube
or what was waking
you up that kind
of made you get into this?
- I was trying to
develop a video game
and obviously being
in that sort of space,
you start becoming aware
of like, well, feminism,
frankly, coming in and attacking
the industry as a whole.
And I was just like,
"Okay, well what is this?"
I looked into it and I was
like, "Okay, this isn't really
in line with the principles
that basically
everyone is espousing.
Why are we stigmatizing men?"
And of course then that leads
on to the stigmatization
of white people
and straight people
and anything that they view
as what they call
a dominant class,
it gets stigmatized in order
to try and tear it down.
And so I started making
videos just in 2013,
I think it was July,
2013 was my first video
where I was just like, "Look,
I don't really agree with this
and I don't really understand
why you're saying it."
And I think...
And looking back, right, I
watched my very first video
a few years ago,
man, I was naive.
(Dave laughing)
- [Carl] Man, I was naive.
- Well, we all
were, we all were.
- Right?
And we were, yeah,
we genuinely were.
It was, it was like, "Okay,
why don't I just explain
why I think you're wrong and
then we'll have a discourse."
And they were like, "Oh,
you're a misogynist."
I was like, "Oh," you
know, and I was outraged.
The first time I was
called a misogynist,
I was genuinely outraged
'cause like of course I'm
not a misogynist, you know,
why would you even say that?
It's fair for me to have a
critique of your philosophy.
And they're like, "No,
you just hate women."
It's like, "Oh, right, okay."
You know, but of
course, you know,
water off a duck's
back these days
because you can't critique
Black Lives Matter, feminism
or anything that without being
an ist and a phobe, you know,
obviously that's become very
apparent that they just use
that as a sort of defense
mechanism, try and shut you up.
But I think that really,
that time has passed.
I think everyone's -
- 10 Years later, the
words don't matter
as much as they
used to back then.
- Exactly, everyone's
like immune
to that kind of
attack now, and, yeah.
And so I just started
talking about these things
from my perspective,
which really is
still the perspective of a
classical liberal, you know.
I've developed an
appreciation of conservatism,
like real sort of halfy
conservatism, you know,
the sort of genuine of bonds
of sentiment that tie together
people and place and community
building outwards to nation
and to humanity, you know,
I've really spent a lot
of time reading their philosophy
because they're actually
really bad at articulating it.
You know, you probably
can't actually name
very many conservative
philosophers,
but you can name dozens
of left wing ones, right.
You know, and so
it's kind of annoying
that the conservatives
are actually quite bad
at telegraphing their message
because actually it's a
really wholesome message.
You know, really what's
the most important thing
in your life?
Well, your family actually,
the people who depend on you.
You know, and so I've
kind of been leaning
into that a bit more.
But you know, I've
still got the same sort
of classical liberal
core where it's like,
well obviously people should
be treated as individuals
in decent ways,
but there's more to the
good life than just being an
atomized individual
on your own, you know,
with just a bunch of things
given to you by the state.
There's actually a lot more
to the good life than that.
And so, yeah, I just
continued developing.
I've matured a lot, which
is never fun to say, right?
(Dave laughing)
Because it's, you know,
you realize, well -
- It depends where
you end up, I suppose.
- Well, yeah, yeah, but
it's never fun to say.
But I've definitely matured a
lot and I started a business
called lotsi.com.
Where we develop sort of,
I hate to say to say it's
right wing philosophy,
but like, I don't really
have a better term for it.
You know, 'cause everything
else seems to be well left wing
philosophy.
- Right.
- Well, I guess, you know,
but what we're really trying
to do is just properly
understand the sort of
metaphysics of what it is
we actually assume
all day, every day.
'Cause we never talk
about the importance
of not just family, 'cause
it's easy to say that.
And it's trite to say that.
It's like, okay, what
about the family,
actually is it this important?
And it's really the
bonds of reliability
on the person, right?
'Cause one thing having
four kids has taught me,
it's the predictability
of each day
is what's really good
for the your children.
It's really what they need.
They need to wake up and
know, dad's gonna do this,
mom's gonna do this.
I'm gonna go to school and
everything will be the same
as it was yesterday and
it'll be the same tomorrow.
And so they can genuinely be
happy in the world around them.
And then when you start
thinking like this, you realize,
God, the people in charge
are totally irresponsible
with everything in our state.
You know, everything
in the country,
everything in the
west, you know?
They're just so cavalier with
the decisions that they make.
And it's like, God, how
can they think like this?
And I think a lot of it is
because we've kind of lent
too much towards liberalism
and not enough towards what
should be a happy marriage
between liberalism
and conservatism.
- I'm with you, brother.
I feel it. I get it.
It's why now I say to
my, I say to my audience,
I can call myself
a conservative.
- Oh yeah.
I'm married to a man that's
not very conservative
in the sense that it
would've been thought of
say 50 years ago.
But I do believe in the family,
and I believe in the
importance of community
and things like that.
Do you think that, you
sort of hinted at this,
but do you think that
liberalism had an inherent flaw
that allowed the
barbarians at the gate
and then kind of to open
the door to the gate
or open the door to the castle?
- The problem, the
problem with liberalism.
And so I spent a
lot of time reading
and researching into liberalism
itself as a philosophy.
'Cause so much of it
goes unsaid, right?
We assume the truth of
all of the presuppositions
underpin liberalism.
But actually there are
some real flaws with it.
And one of the main
things I took away from it
is that liberalism is an
incomplete philosophy, right?
It's not a philosophy for life.
What it is is kind of
a way of recognizing
when the state is going too far.
When you are being
actively oppressed,
which we've seen recently in
the example of Russell Brand,
actively being persecuted.
I mean, what's happening
to Russell Brand
by the British
government at the moment
is a violation of Article
39 of Magna Carta.
- Yeah.
- Like a man without the
lawful judgment of his peers
under the law of the land
shall not be transgressed upon,
oppressed upon by the state.
That's literally what it says.
And this is what we're watching
happening in real time.
So it's, it's not enough
to just be a liberal,
but liberalism is
great in that regard,
in that sort of narrow band.
It's really good to say, look,
these are the rules
and the boundaries
that have been kind of learned
from English
political tradition.
And then that way they can
be spread around the world.
Brilliant idea.
But on the other side,
it lacks a kind of
normative doctrine.
As in, you know, you get up
and what should you do today?
And actually liberalism doesn't
have any answers to this.
And so this gives
the whole world of
where conservatives and
Christians in particular
have lots of good answers
for what you should do today.
No, you should get up, what?
You should make
your kids breakfast.
You know, you should
get 'em to school.
You should go to work.
You should uphold the
right ordering of the world
in your actions, in the
character of what you do.
And liberalism really
can't say that.
And so that's why liberalism
is kind of vulnerable.
'Cause if actually you
take away the Christianity,
take away the
conservative values,
then you can take the liberal
principles of freedom,
equality and say, right,
I can explode these
out into everything.
You know, the freedom
to never be bothered
by another human being.
So you're just an isolated
individual who's there.
I'm free to take as
many drugs I want,
I'm free to just become
dependent on the government.
Oh, we want equality now.
Right, okay, well, how
do you get equality?
Well, you've gotta make
sure that the lowest
never have, the highest never
have more than the lowest.
So you've gotta tax
them to equality.
It's like, well, hang on
a second, that's not good,
or just, or fair.
- I would say
that's not liberal,
but it's what liberalism
is devolved into.
You're basically
saying there was no,
there was no stop
sign along the way.
So it was sort of
exactly inevitable
that this would happen.
- Once you take away all
of the other considerations
about like the
richness of human life,
then actually you can
take liberal principles
and explode them into things
they're not meant to be,
you know?
And this is the problem I think
that the left has right now
and why so many
people are just like,
okay, I used to be part of
the left, but I'm not that.
- So I guess it doesn't shock
you then when you look back
and you go, okay, you were
doing these videos saying,
Hey liberals wake up.
And then a guy like Dave
Rubin from the very far left
Young Turks is kind of waking up
and then he's talking to you.
And then we've seen
a series, you know,
Bill Maher kind
of half wakes up.
We get a series of people
that kind of wake up.
A lot of 'em end up
going back the other way
'cause the mob freaks
them out and they can't,
they're not brave enough, okay.
But I guess you think that
it's sort of just like
an inevitability of a liberal
who's really thinking, right?
Or something like that.
- Yeah. I would say it's
about intellectual honesty
and moral courage.
Because there are
lots of people who are
in a very sort of
cloying society in
places like California
where there it's
very oppressive.
Like for all of the freedom
that they claim to have,
actually, you don't have the
freedom to say, I disagree.
And this I think is really
the fundamental precept
of what freedom could be.
If you're not free to disagree
with what everyone else
is doing, then how, in what
way are you really free?
And I am,
it was probably only
a matter of time until
people like yourself, people
like me turned around and said,
hang on, no.
I just don't agree with the
way that you view the world.
I don't agree with
what you're doing.
And I'm willing to shed the
label of being left wing
if it means living
an authentic life
true to my values and true
to what I believe is correct
and right and good.
And I think there
are a lot of people
who frankly lack
that moral courage,
who are still trapped there.
Do you think part of that,
it's not just that
they're afraid of the mob,
but there's something
so baked into culture,
the default of
culture that is left.
And I know these terms are
sort of becoming increasingly
meaningless, which
is nice to an extent,
but that's what they're
really afraid of.
Like, it's automatically like,
oh, if you are not for equity,
if you're, if you don't
think boys or girls,
you're automatically
framed as a bad guy now.
And that, people just
don't wanna walk from that.
- Yeah.
I think the thing
that the left has done
very, very effectively is
claimed to have a monopoly
on morality,
because it defines morality
in quite a narrow way itself.
It has to be essentially
rationally calculable.
But actually, if
you think about it,
a lot of what we actually
do that is moral,
is actually very sentimental
and habitual, right?
We didn't think about it.
We just do it because it's
the right thing to do.
And so if you are
actually taking principles
like freedom inequality,
well actually you can
destroy the family
with those principles.
You know, you don't owe
anything to your parents
and you can't say that your
your father is superior to you
because that's not equality.
And so you're not
bound by being,
you didn't choose your
parents but you...
And so by the principles
of freedom, equality,
you can be unbound
from your own family.
And like children can
have no responsibility
to not only their parents,
but their own country and
to anything like that.
It's like, God, this is
actually quite horrific, right?
And this is a sort of
radical form of morality.
This is really unusual
like nowhere else on earth.
You know, even, even, you know,
from very, very sort
of loose civilizations
where the society isn't very
tightly knit to, you know,
deeply tribal societies
where literally everyone
in the tribe is
sort of like second
or third cousins or something.
You know, everything outside
of left-wing morality
is kind of on a continuum
and has been normal for
almost all human societies
to some degree, for all of
human, for all the time.
And it's only since about
the French Revolution,
incidentally, where this
kind of radical morality
asserts itself and says,
right, this is the left
and this is the absolute
liberation of the individual.
Really, ultimately
what they want
is from the flesh itself, right?
And this is why they're
stigmatizing the body now.
Oh that child needs transition.
It's like, are you mad?
You know, there's no way a child
can give informed
consent to transition.
They can't give informed
consent get a loan.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
Tattoo
- Yeah. Tattoo, you know?
They can't chop off their
own genitals you maniacs.
You know, and so this
radical liberatory morality
is something really quite new.
And you are right.
It's not just the
identity of the left,
it's not just that
the trapped in it.
I actually think
that they're afraid
that if they kind of
accept, hang on a second,
I bought into all
of this wholesale,
then what they're saying is
I was being evil actually.
And that's a really difficult
thing to look yourself
in the mirror and say, oh,
everything I did was wrong.
Every time I cheered
on a teenage girl
who got a breasts
removed and stitched up,
I was ruining someone's
life actually.
And so it's easier to say no,
everything else about
human morality is wrong
and oppressive and
stigmatizing, blah blah blah.
And everything about this
is just perfectly good.
It's just, they're bigots.
It's a way easier
thing to do than that.
- All right, so you just
gave me the perfect segue
to bring up something that
I have never talked about
on this show.
And in some ways I don't
really want to talk about,
but having you here,
I kind of feel like I
have to talk about it,
which is an old colleague
of mine at the Young Turk
Ana Kasparian who has said some
really, really unbelievable,
horrible, dishonest
things about me.
It's not important, actually,
I'm not gonna
repeat any of them.
The internet sort of knows
what they are, is what it is.
But we were extremely good
friends, invited to my wedding,
et cetera, et cetera.
But apparently,
and I only know this
from some of the videos
that you've done, she's
having some sort of wake up.
She's waking up
out of this leftism
and this sort of mental
prison that you're describing.
You think you can get
her over the edge?
- I don't wanna try
because she's been
very embedded,
very publicly in what I
would call radical left-wing
morality for a very long time.
And Solzhenitsyn has
this particular quote
that probably everyone
knows where the,
a lot of the time these people,
even when reality is
hitting them in the face
with the consequences
of their own ideology,
they won't admit it.
Well actually, Ana is
being hit in the face
with the consequences
of this morality.
And is going, okay, I was wrong.
'Cause she, I think
she got assaulted
by a homeless person
outside of her house.
I think that she's very
aware that the trans lobby
have got to the point where
they're going to degrade
her status as woman to
merely birthing person
or something like that.
And she's, and you know,
I'm sure she pays way too
much in taxes to Gavin Newsom,
which I hear she's not
a fan of his policies.
And so she's got to the point
where now it's affecting her.
And it's like, hang on a second.
Actually we need to
arrest criminals.
Actually giving half my wages
to the state is not moral,
is not moral.
This isn't making the
world a bad place.
Actually, a lot of the
things the left are saying
such as there is no difference
between men and women,
these are not truths, right?
And you can't really build
morality on truths, actually.
And so I think that
she's come to the point
where it's untenable for her.
You know, I think that Jen
is still essentially wedded
to the left and
left wing morality.
And so I think he's
afraid of going,
of looking the reflection
in the mirror and saying,
look, this is actually
kind of hideous.
It's kind of, maybe this
sort of Dorian Gay painting
might be a better thing, right?
Going and looking
at the painting
and looking at the rot on
the face of the painting
and being like, oh my God,
is that secretly me
in my heart, you know?
And so I am actually
tremendously sympathetic, right?
And I realize that
that's not probably
what you would like to
hear 'cause she was...
- Well she's been unbelievably
nasty and dishonest.
But in a weird way, I am,
because I am
sympathetic to people
that are waking up to the truth.
And I would want someone to
get to the end of the road
and, you know,
we could still have some
disagreements about this or that
or the other thing.
And I'm not expecting,
nor request an apology,
but it would be nice to see
someone that has some influence
waking up to truth.
Like that's pretty good.
- A part of me feels that
she's kind of the victim
of the ideology.
And I'm not trying to say
that she's got no agency
or anything like that, but...
- Well, she used to say, but
way back when that, you know,
when she got there
at the Young Turks,
she knew nothing about politics
and Jan taught her
everything, right?
- And so, and if...
- Congratulations.
- And if you are, you know,
you're a host on
a massive channel,
you've got thousands and
thousands of people every day
either reinforcing
what your biases are
that you've been taught,
or castigating you for
having an independent thought
of your own.
You can see how someone would,
well, I'll just
move away from that
and into the safe
place where I'm allowed
to say left-wing things.
And there's a part
of me that, I mean,
it wasn't Jordan Pea who
called it the Mind Virus.
- Well now it's sort
of everybody saying it,
but I think Gadd Saad may
have said sad it originally.
- That's correct.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"The parasitic Mind"
was one of his books.
- Exactly. Sorry, Gadd.
(laughing)
I think he's right to
call it a mind virus.
And I think when you
have a kind of disease,
it's not necessarily your fault
if you are ill
tempered, basically.
And so there's a
part of me that is,
that doesn't see her in
necessarily as being the author
of the actions, she
was kind of operating
in a pre-planned way.
If someone is an
apostate from leftism,
that's worse than being
a heretic, you know,
that it's always worse
to be the apostate.
And so it's predictable
that she would act that way.
And one would hope now
that with her having
a kind of Damascene
moment of her own,
being like, hang on a second,
these people are evil
and wrong and then cruel.
They're being cruel to me.
Maybe she'll think well,
in a way that I was cruel
to people I loved actually.
And maybe I owe them an apology.
- Was the most
shocking part to you
as you were talking
about this stuff
and sort of seeing the
hate from, you know,
your side, so to speak.
What I was more amazed by,
yes, I was shocked by the hate
and I ended up developing
an autoimmune disease
because of it and lost
like 40% of my hair.
I mean, I could not believe
how much hate I was getting
from the supposed good guys.
So I'm not saying
that was nothing.
But the thing that actually
shocked me more so,
and even to this day still
shocks me in a weird way,
is how conservatives who
I still might disagree
with on some of
the social issues.
I'm begrudgingly pro-choice.
I'm married to a man, as I said.
Like there might
be some stuff there
that my life is
not traditionally
conservative, obviously.
I get nothing but
love from them.
- Yeah.
- Nothing but love
and I am invited to
religious things of various
denominations all the time.
And I find them acting
far more liberally.
Did that part shock you?
I mean, well is that a fair
estimation for you too?
That the conservatives who
you were probably disagreeing
with maybe on
taxes at one point?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And yeah, no.
And in retrospect
no, but at the time,
yes.
- Yes. Yeah.
- 'Cause one of the things
about conservative morality
in itself is it's
very concerned about,
if you picture two people
who know each other,
you could draw like,
you know, Donny Darko,
he's got the sort of tunnel
coming from his chest.
You could draw one of those
connecting the
two people, right?
You can call that that's
their relationship
and that can wax and wane
and grow in intensity.
So like with my wife, you know,
a very, very shining
sort of connection.
'cause we know each
other very well.
You know, we love each
other and we've got,
you know, lots of
responsibility.
Everything's very bound up.
And so the conservatives are
very concerned about that.
And that is maintained by
goodwill. It's just goodwill.
It's about being polite to
the other person, be caring,
doing acts of unexpected
kindness for the other person.
You know, you pick up
some flowers for your wife
or you get you take the rubbish
out or something, right?
- You don't rampage the
city when you're protesting.
How about that?
- Yeah, yeah.
- They always clean up
when they're protesting.
- Exactly. And, and
yeah, no, exactly.
'Cause that sort of Donny
Darko bond is everywhere
to the conservative.
They project it onto
the place they live.
And so they'll pick up some
rubbish off the street.
They won't just throw
rubbish on the floor, right?
'Cause these love bonds that
come out of their chest,
they, like, I think it's
David Hume who says,
we kind of spread ourselves
on the world around us.
And that's totally true.
And that's what the
conservatives are like.
And so it would shock
me if a conservative
wasn't sensitive to that.
And so even if they
don't agree with you,
they still view you as you.
You are not just a bad smell
or a bad thing to
them, you know?
And so they'll treat you
with respect and decency.
- And actually curiosity too.
Which liberals are the ones
that are supposed to be curious.
But I found conservatives,
they couldn't figure
out what to make of me
at the beginning.
This guy's a lefty, he's gay,
like what's going on here?
And then, that was it.
- But actually, they live their
lives by a code of decency.
Whereas the left
has abandoned that.
They've said, none
of that is morality.
And so they don't need
to live their lives
by a code of decency.
- So when, sorry, so when you
see now what's going on in LA
and San Francisco,
and I'm sure you guys
have some versions of it
happening in the UK,
like the places that that
liberalism fully took root,
which ultimately ended
up in this progressive,
now communist psychosis,
like, it seems like the
obvious end game to you?
Like, or is it not
over there even?
Like, when you go
to San Francisco
and see the devastation can't
get much worse than that.
I don't think.
- It can always get worse.
- And it is getting
worse. That's the thing.
San Francisco, in fact is
probably a case study of,
it's probably gonna be
in, in 50 years time
there'll be tragedies
written about San Francisco.
'Cause I mean, I was
talking to your producers
before the show, like they're
too young to remember.
But I remember when
I was a teenager,
San Francisco and Los Angeles
were legendary cities.
- Yeah.
- Legendary.
Like the idea that
anyone would leave,
voluntarily leave these places
is just mind boggling, right?
But you can see how it's been,
they've both been
driven into the ground.
I mean, I was in San Francisco,
I think it was 2018 last,
and even then it was like the
zombie apocalypse that hit.
Like you were walking around,
it was literally zombie-fi
drug users on the street.
And I was just like, oh
my God, I can't imagine.
- It's way worse now. Way worse.
- I can't imagine how
much worse it is now.
- Yeah.
- But it's essentially the
reduction of everything good.
That's what the communists want.
And they won't say that
that's what they want
and they'll have some ideal,
but if you have to
equalize everything,
then the only thing you can have
is the lowest
common denominator.
So there's only one way to go.
And that's down.
- So would you say from
an American context,
our Democrat Party and from
a a British perspective,
your Labor Party,
are they just like the party
members and the party elites,
are they just using these people
as the pawns in this game?
Or do you think
they believe it too?
Like Gavin Newsom destroyed
San Francisco as mayor,
then becomes governor
of San- of California
and in essence is
destroying California.
Million people have
left in three years.
Like what do you
think about the people
that are actually in charge?
- Just a quick thing.
The Labor Party in Britain
has actually changed.
When Jeremy Corbin was in
charge, that it was exactly.
- [Dave] Yeah, it
was going, there.
- It was exactly that
kind of radical leftism.
But actually Kier Starmer has
kicked him out of the party
and kicked loads of his
supporters outta the party,
and essentially stolen it
back from the radical left.
So actually the Labor
Party in Britain
is more right wing than
the Conservative Party
at the moment.
- I know, it's crazy.
- How would you say
they're more right wing?
- Because they, for example,
last year the conservatives
let in a million
1.2 million immigrants
into the country.
Well, under the Labor Party
as it's constituted now,
when they began the process
of mass immigration,
they topped off at
about half a million.
So actually the
conservatives are way worse.
And the Labor Party
will probably reduce
the overall amount
of immigration.
- Is that just bad governance
by the conservatives
or it was like a plan
to really let it,
I mean, I know, I guess
that's the endless debate.
- If I had an answer
to that question.
As far as I'm concerned, the
Conservative Party is traitors.
- Yeah.
- Right?
Weak-willed,
spineless, traitors.
'Cause they're not
really conservatives.
If they were actually
conservatives,
they would just say
no to a lot of things.
And really that's the problem,
is we just need an
executive who will say,
no, we're not doing that.
No, we're not doing that.
And that's really
all it would take
to turn our
civilizations around.
Is have the moral
fortitude to just refuse
when a ridiculous
request is made.
It's actually not that radical,
but the morality that overlays
what we're talking about,
it is a radical change.
It'd mean jet sitting
the extreme left.
It would just, sorry,
we're just not gonna do that
and we're not gonna
listen to you anymore.
But going back to the Democrats,
totally captured and
irredeemably, so it looks like.
- Give me an idea.
I can smuggle in.
- I wish there was one.
- To do what happened
with your Labor Party?
- I wish there was one.
- Well how did it
happen with your,
well, I guess Corbin
was so outta whack that,
that maybe it became
too obvious, right?
- With the Labor
Party, what it is,
is there's a kind of
old English socialism
or British socialism
that is rooted
in these kind of
conservative morays.
Where it's like, no, we
love the country around us.
We just want to have the
National Health Service.
We just want some social
support because we need it.
You know, there are poor
people in the country
who need help.
And actually, because
we're a small old country,
there's a lot more sort
of social texture there.
And so it's easier to
pull on that sort of,
it's a lot more conservative.
And so the traditional
labor voters, themselves,
they're insanely
socially conservative.
Like they don't
believe in any of this
radical left winging stuff.
And so Corbin had a bunch
of, essentially students,
who supported him
and joined the party.
And Keir Starmer
just got the vote
of the majority of the party,
which was about two
thirds of the party.
And he's not conservative,
but he's not a radical leftist.
He's, honestly, he's
really not very bright.
So he's not really anything,
but he's just doing what he
can do to get power, right?
And so that's kind
of what happened.
In America, honestly,
I really don't like
calling people evil, right?
I don't like saying,
oh, that those people are
just malevolent, right?
I don't like saying that.
But it's really hard
to be able to formulate
any other kind of reason why
someone like Gavin Newsom
or Joe Biden or
whoever would just lie
about what it is
that's happening.
They will tell untruths
about what you can see
in front of very eyes.
And they'll say, no, this
is what progress looks like.
It say, okay, but progress
looks like literally
the zombie apocalypse.
You know, I don't want that.
Whatever you wanna call
that, I'm against it.
And I'm for the complete
opposite, you know?
I'm for growth and regeneration,
wholesomeness and decency.
You are for literally giving
people drugs, you know,
giving drug addicts needles.
- And it's not like you
don't see what happens
because of it.
He's got a long track
record of what happens
because of it.
Right, it's interesting
because Biden,
I don't think Biden is
actually inherently evil.
I think he's a deeply
corrupt part of a machine
and he's been in it way too long
and he's completely mentally
compromised right now.
So I don't think he really
knows maybe how evil
the machine is using him.
Something like
that where Newsom,
I think it's very clear he
knows what the outcome is
and he's still going for it.
So you don't see a
way, you don't see...
I mean, look, RFK Junior,
I would say is an
old school liberal,
much like his uncle and father.
And the party has
completely eliminated him.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I mean they've been
ruthless in the demonization
of him as well.
I didn't really know anything
about him, to be honest.
- You know, they won't
put him on CNN now.
Jake Tapper said
he's too extreme.
He's too extreme
to interview him,
but he'll put on DeSantis.
Now obviously, I don't
think DeSantis is extreme.
But the point is, he's saying
that the most conservative guy
I'll put him on, but I
won't have this Democrat on.
And did you know this,
that the DNC has so rigged
the primary for Biden
that if RFK shows up in Iowa
or any of the early
primary states,
the votes automatically
go to Biden.
'Cause they know Biden
doesn't have to campaign.
So they're saying if anyone
else running shows up there,
the votes go, like.
- It's so obvious,
it's so naked.
And it's hard to say that these
people are not malevolent.
They know what they're doing.
- So what do you do
with that in a society?
What do you, what do you
think we do with that?
I mean, I wanted
defeat their ideas,
but now they have
raised probably
two generations of the
next set of clones.
- It's hard to say, isn't it?
Because one thing that I find
interesting about America
that I don't feel about
my own country is,
the pressure, it feels
like Americans are under.
Like, I hear the word
fight a lot in America.
You know, we're fighting
for your rights,
we're fighting for equal
pay, we're fighting for this,
we're fighting for that.
And people on the writer,
you know, Stephen Crowder uses
the word fight a lot as well.
And I'm not having,
I'm not throwing shade,
it's just, 'cause, I mean,
it's a totally
rational response,
if you've got a well-oiled,
vast machine that
is not trustworthy
and is frankly totalitarian.
I don't wanna say anything too
mad for YouTube, obviously.
- Nah, we're on
Rumble. It's okay.
- Oh, okay.
Oh, stole the election and
stuff like this, right?
- Yeah. (laughing)
- And 81 million...
- You can say
whatever you want here.
- 81 Million votes, he's more
popular than Barack Obama was.
What do you know?
If you've got this kind
of well old machine
that is constantly
trying to take over,
it's got this voracious
appetite, it just will not stop.
Then what do you do? You can't
not fight back against it.
But then you're in
some kind of social war
where the boundary lines are
actually really clearly drawn.
You know, it's people
who are willing
to be tolerant of others,
and this radical left.
And the radical
left is a powerful
force in your country.
You know, it's not nearly
as powerful in my country.
It's actually little more
insidious in my country.
And so we, I don't feel
that we are constantly
in this kind of social
war, whereas Americans,
it feels that they're
under a lot of pressure.
You know, and there's,
and I can see it on
the faces of Americans
when I'm walking around, man.
You know, I can see like they
feel the world around them
is high stakes.
You know, there's
a lot going on.
And you know, it's
not just Miami.
I've been to lots of
places in America where...
- You were seeing in Miami.
I see a lot of happy
people in Miami,
but I'm.
- There are.
- I'm so hopped up on
vitamin D down here.
- There are lots of
happy peoples people.
But they're also, the people
who are running everything,
look kind of grim.
They, you know, their
lives are quite serious
and they're quite
close to the edge.
They're a lot closer to the
edge than they want to be.
And I think all of this sort
of just combines to this,
the kind of,
I don't think it should
be this way, you know?
And I don't think it
always was this way.
'Cause every American
I met when I was young
was really happy go lucky.
It was actually kind of adorable
how kind of just innocent
Americans were, right?
And it was just cheery.
And they would be, they
would have the same kind of,
we're in it together mentality
that we have in England.
But now you've got,
the Democrats are
like half the country
and or like a third
of the country,
and then the Republicans
are the third
and the exhausted
independencies in the middle.
- Yeah.
- They must be
exhausted with politics.
- Pick a side.
- Yeah, you know.
But you don't blame,
I can't blame for,
like, look man,
I'm just tired of this.
'Cause it it feels like
Americans are constantly
in the state of combat.
And I don't envy it, right?
- Would you say that's partly
because maybe we're just kind of
in our adolescence
with all this,
where you guys are
an older country
and it's just a
different attitude.
- I think this is an excuse
that Americans have been making
for a long time.
'Cause actually you're
not that young a country.
You know, as republics go,
250 years is pretty
good, actually.
You're probably getting
to the end of the lifecycle
of Republic, right?
Historically...
- I'm bullish on
Florida, so, you know.
- Historically they don't
last that much longer.
And you should be as well.
- Yeah.
- But it's, I'm glad I'm
not trapped in a country
with the Democrats, right?
Because I wouldn't want to
have to deal with these people
on a daily basis.
And I wouldn't want
them to be a facet
of my local politics, right?
- So when you see the
Federalist system working here,
and now you're here and
you're bouncing around
and doing Cali and
Texas and Florida.
Like, you dig that,
like you see the strength
in that, obviously.
- Oh, yeah, yeah. absolutely.
And, I mean, I think DeSantis
has done a brilliant job
with Florida.
You know, I've been
following DeSantis career
for about five or six years now,
and he's been doing great
and going from
strength to strength.
We can talk about the
election thing in a minute
if you want.
- Yeah sure.
- But it's the fact that you're
trapped with the serpents
in your country.
It's like, oh my God, why
does it have to be that way?
Why do we have to be
with people who literally
don't respect the legitimacy
of anything that you do?
They literally hate you
because of your race
and your gender
and your sexuality.
I mean, not you, but like,
you know, the average.
- No, they still hate me.
No, they still hate
me. I don't count.
No, I'm what you said before,
I'm the guy that walked
away, so I'm double apostate.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
Like, but they genuinely
hate, you know,
it's a genuine hate
that animates them.
And it's like, right, okay,
why would you wanna be
trapped in a country
with a bunch of people
who literally hate you?
'Cause this goes back
to the very nature
of what it is to have a
state in the first place.
I mean, Aristotle, two and
a half thousand years ago
thought there
couldn't be a state
if it's not based on
goodwill and friendship.
He thought that
friendship was the basis
of any political organization.
And so now you look
at it and you're like,
okay, but those people
are trying to destroy us,
like actively trying
to destroy us.
They're trying to
get us shut down.
make us homeless.
They're trying to make us
destitute on the streets,
like Belisarius or something.
You know, like we're just
gonna be on the street
in Rome blind and
begging for pennies.
You know, that's where
they would have you,
given the choice.
And so, okay, why do
my fellow countrymen
think that way about me?
You know, that's what I
think the average American
should be asking themselves.
Say, hang on, why should
we have to live like this
with people like that
who don't respect
that we are human beings.
That we're not just citizens,
we are your countrymen.
You know, there is
meant to be a bond,
a glowing bond between us.
And you've severed that and
called me a Nazi, you know,
and you want to
try and destroy me.
That can't go on. That
just can't go on forever.
And so at some point,
something has to give
and it has to be their
attitude towards you.
- Right.
But they damn shame of it,
and before we're beating
a dead horse with this,
the damn shame is that
everyone that talks about it
from that perspective
gets annihilated.
- Oh yeah.
- And therein lies the rub.
So it's like, okay, you wake
up and now congratulations.
They're doing it to you.
And you either give up
or you end up like us.
Which is not too bad.
- Yeah, yeah. No,
we've done fine.
- Yeah, it's all right.
But alright, well let's
shift for a second.
'Cause actually
speaking of doing fine,
you not only helped
me when sort of,
I was waking up to this stuff
and everyone was saying,
you gotta talk to this
Sargon of Akkad guy.
And I don't even know
that I knew that you're,
were you even public at that?
But did I know that
your name was Carl?
Was that even a thing?
Probably not, you were just
doing this thing, okay.
But then a couple years later
you were also instrumental
in something else that
happened sort of accidentally,
because you and I were two
of the first political guys
on Patreon.
And everyone remembers
Patreon was sort of the first
crowd fund, monthly
donation site.
And well, I'll let
you tell the story,
but basically you got kicked
off Patreon and it literally,
what happened
subsequently after that
changed the trajectory
of my life, so.
- Well, there were a bunch
of white nationalists
who really didn't like the fact
that I wasn't a
white nationalist
and they were attacking me.
And I kind of lost
my cool on a podcast.
It wasn't on my channel, it
was on someone else's channel.
It wasn't on my Patreon
or anything like that.
- So that, wait, that's
a really important point.
It did not occur on
your Patreon, what
you're about to say.
- Or my channel.
- Or you or YouTube channel
that was being
funded on Patreon.
So you were on someone
else's channel.
Okay.
- Yes.
And they were attacking me.
I lost my cool
and I said things I
shouldn't have said, right?
And I'm, you know, more
than happy to accept that.
And looking back on
it, I'm like, oh.
- But you didn't say
anything racist actually,
you said a word.
- I was saying at the,.
- Yeah, but you were also not
using it pejoratively really,
you were using it in like,
sort of like a jokey, like.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
It was meant to be humorous.
- You were being
racist in the nature
of the way you were saying it.
- No, no.
And I wasn't saying
it to a black person
or anything like that, right?
But in retrospect, probably
I'm wise to have said it.
I totally accept.
And I guess one of these
people had sent that to Patreon
and Patreon like, oh,
well you're not allowed to
have your Patreon anymore.
I was like, okay,
but I didn't actually violate
your terms of service,
'cause I didn't post any
of that on the platform,
or nor was it on my channel.
In fact, the person
whose channel it was on
was a really small
YouTuber as well.
- Yeah, it was tiny, and
the audio wasn't great.
Like it was, yeah.
- You would have to
really go outta your way
to find it, right?
But that was it.
And then there was a huge
reaction to that actually.
You know, Sam Harris
closed his Patreon
and you know, Jordan
Peterson set up Thinkspot,
you set up Locals
and it was just like,
it was a massive thing.
It was really heartening
to see as well.
There were loads of
people like, no, actually,
you know, you can't
just ruin people, right?
You can't.
- And you were basically
making your living
from that at that
point, right, right?
So you have a family, you got
four kids, the whole thing,
they just take you out
basically overnight.
And yeah, for me,
I mean I started,
Jordan and I, we were working
on the Thinkspot thing,
and then Jordan
obviously got ill,
but that's what led to Locals,
which led obviously to
a lot of other success,
and Rumbles, so that
you're allowed to say
whatever you want on this show.
Which is pretty sweet.
- Yeah.
- But now you see it, you
referenced it earlier.
Now your government as we speak,
is coming after Russell
Brand and for Rumble.
I put sending out a
letter to pressure them
to say that a guy who
just has allegations
against him should not
be able to make a living.
It's psychotic.
But we've been through this
again, that's my point.
We've been through this before.
- I mean, at least in my case,
the government didn't
come for me, you know?
At least in my case
it was just Jack Conte
over in California who decided,
oh, I'll just take
this executive action.
To have a sitting MP, right,
using the authority of a
government committee to,
it wasn't just Rumble,
there was TikTok,
Twitter and Facebook, and
who knows why YouTube just,
you know, I don't know that
they sent a letter to YouTube.
- Well, YouTube did it
already. I think that's why.
- [Carl] I guess
YouTube was just...
- Or they knew YouTube was
gonna play ball, right?
- Right, yeah.
But the point is that's,
I mean, that's literally
against the Magna Carta.
That's the against
the very spirit
and principle of common law.
And it's staggering
that that person
hasn't resigned yet, right?
Time of recording, that
person hasn't resigned.
I mean, maybe they will have
done by the end of this.
But it's just so beyond the pale
and that's a member of the
Conservative Party, you know?
So they've bought
into, 'cause I mean,
I don't know what
the allegations
against Russell Brand,
whether they're true
or not, you know?
- It's a moot point altogether.
- Exactly. It's
irrelevant, right?
Because okay, well then
if he's found guilty,
there will be a punishment
prescribed under the law,
that great, then
he can be punished.
You know, as far as I'm aware,
there are no charges
against him yet, you know,
which makes this all the worse.
'Cause mean he's alleged,
it's really just a very,
very aggressive rumor
that is being spread about him.
You know, there are
no legal charges.
- And I know a little
something about your tabloids.
They do make things up.
Right, is that fair to say?
I watched The Crown, I know
what they did to Diana.
And then Martin Bashir,
the guy who did it then
became a huge star
on MSNBC in America.
- The tabloids do
have a habit of having
to retract a lot of things.
The BBC as well, in fact.
So yes, it's entirely possible
that these are not true
and/or exaggerated
and misinterpreted
something like this.
I don't know. Like I
said, I have no idea.
But the point that you're
making is exactly right.
This is mad. This is
way beyond the pale.
Even if he is convicted for
all of the things to say,
that still doesn't mean he
should have his livelihood
taken away from him.
No criminals get that.
- It's so profoundly psychotic.
It would be the equivalent
of a guy who sells shoes
for a living, going
to a grocery store
and stealing an Apple,
and then YouTube saying to
him, you can't work anymore.
And somehow the shoe
store agreeing with it.
Like it really.
But do you see this as like,
like this is the fight
more than anything.
Like the online fight now is
all we've got left, right?
Otherwise, everybody's
gonna turn into an N P C.
- It's about the legitimacy
of you as a person, right?
That's what it is.
Like, look, do I get to
have an internet access,
account on the internet?
Do I get to engage in
society with everyone else?
Or should there be a
particular privilege class
and everyone else literally
reduced to being a basket case,
you know, who can't get,
you know, a bank account or a
YouTube account or whatever,
a Twitter account.
You know, is that
a just society?
And the conservative
will say no,
everyone actually is a
kind of unique human being
who's a part of this tapestry
that we call society.
And even, okay, if they
do something wrong,
then we have a law that
prescribes what the punishment
for that wrongdoing is.
And that's as far as it goes.
You know, we don't ruin them
because of course the
conservatives think, well,
people can learn their mistakes,
learn from their
mistakes and change.
And actually it's not
right to destroy someone.
'Cause essentially it's kind
of like a digital death penalty
that they're trying
to give Russell Brand.
It's like, Hey, he hasn't
even been convicted.
And even if he is guilty,
there are punishments for it.
- But what do you think the
end game for them would be?
Not for a guy like, okay,
so you scare the hell,
you maybe destroy Russell Brand
and you go for the people
that are backing him
and the tech that
backs it and all that,
which is clearly what this is.
About, you know, the day
before that the Russell thing
went out, there was a massive
hit piece about Rumble
and the Guardian then...
- Oh, was that.
- Yeah.
Then the piece comes out
from the House of Commons.
Like, it's just like,
it's just so obvious,
like we've been
through this before,
but what do you think
the end game is?
Like, okay, you can take
out a Russell Brand,
you can take out
a Tucker Carlson,
whoever you can take,
you can take out Carl,
you can take out Dave.
But if you take out
millions of people
who can't participate
in society,
like what do they think is
gonna happen to those people?
Maybe it's what they want
to happen to those people.
- They're definitely going
for total control, right?
It's definitely about asserting
a kind of internet
wide dominance.
So they are the ones
who have the authority
to say yes or no,
which is totally alien
to the sort of English
speaking experience, right?
'Cause we're used to there
being a strong division
between the state and society,
and saying, no, look,
society is pluralistic.
We all get to have our own
little domains and gardens,
and we get to grow
our little things.
And if they grow
then that's great.
And if they don't
then that's our fault
and it's up to us, right?
And so Russell
Brand, again, for me,
the classical liberal
slash conservative,
well, you know, I'm not
even a fan of Russell Brand.
I remember Russell
Brand being on TV
and he was really annoying.
Really, really annoying.
- I said, when we covered
this the other day,
I was like, I don't know that
I've ever seen a movie of his.
I've interviewed him and I like
him a lot, I really do now.
And it's been fun seeing his
evolution that, you know,
we're referencing earlier, but.
- In Britain,
Russell Brand's been famous
for about 25 years, right?
And the before we
had the internet,
and so you had four
channels on TV, right?
And Russell Brand
would be on one of them
and he'd be really
annoying, right?
'Cause he was, you
know, a young man
who's just Russell Brand.
And so I was never a fan, right?
But the point is, that's fine.
I don't need to be
a fan of his, right.
I don't need to be a fan.
I don't need to have
anything to do with him
or anything that he does.
It's meant to be a free society.
He can grow his YouTube
channel, his Rumble channel,
his Twitter, whatever.
He should be able
to go out and do
and say whatever he likes.
And if I feel the need to
criticize him or contradict him,
I should have my domain from
where I can do that as well.
And that's what a pluralistic
society actually looks like.
But that of course is not
what they're creating.
And you are right,
what's the CEO of Rumble's name?
- Chris Pavlovsky.
- Yeah.
I mean that genuinely
took courage.
- He's a great human. Yeah,
he's a great human being.
- To turn around and
give the UK government,
just that kind of response
takes genuine courage,
because everyone can see there
is a kind of network of power
that is above the national
level at this point.
I dunno what people
wanna call it,
like the World Economic
Forum or anything like that.
Like, but there is clearly
some kind of international
network of power
that is left wing
and it wants to have
complete managerial control
of the society, down to
the everything that you do
from every level.
It wants that. And
it's trying to get it.
And that's why when
there were competitors
to Patreon that popped up,
they instantly got pulled.
It's like, no, we're
not having that.
And that's what they're
gonna try and do with Rumble.
- Yeah.
- And that's my genuine fear.
- Fortunately, R!umble's
on its own wires
and its own infrastructure,
which makes it much
more of a threat.
You know, even Twitter,
he's on Amazon AWS,
this is a problem.
- It's a massive problem.
But it goes even
further than that.
Because we've seen
them debank people.
For example, Nigel Farage
very recently got his bank,
and there was a massive...
- Wait, can you talk about
that one for a little bit?
'Cause I only hit it on
the show for a moment.
But Nigel Farage, who
at one point was like
basically the most influential
politician in your country.
Who I've had the pleasure
of having many drinks with
over time.
And the man likes to,
he'll take a gin and tonic
at any time of the day,
but he has been.
So is he officially
debanked at this point?
- Okay, so it was a
very big deal, right?
It happened a few months ago
where the bank is called
Coutts, I think it was called.
And it's the bank that
the Queen uses, right?
And so you've got to have a
certain level of money in there,
or they claim you have to
have a certain level of money
in there, but that's
not really true, right?
You know, obviously, you know,
your fortunes go up and down.
But one day they
turned around and said,
well actually we don't
like Nigel Farage
and we're going
to close his bank.
And so Nigel Farage put out
a piece on Twitter and said,
well, they're closing my bank.
I dunno why.
And they said, oh, it's just
'cause for the, you know,
the Oh, oh, you don't have
enough money in there?
Oh, we've got excuses.
Don't worry about it.
But Nigel Farage sent in
a freedom of information
request to Coutts.
And legally they have to give
him the documents he's after.
And he gets one document
as minutes of a meeting
where they literally say,
Nigel Farage is like some
sort of right-wing extremist
and we don't agree
with his values
and so we don't want
him banking with us.
And so there was
enough public pressure
that the conservatives, even
the conservatives had to like,
well, okay, it's not on for you
to just take people's bank
accounts away from them.
Because of course
in the modern era,
you need that to exist.
And so Nudger Farage actually
got his bank account back.
He won this battle, right?
And so, and that's great.
It's always nice to
have the win, but again,
why are we trapped
in civilizations
where there are people
trying to ruin us, you know?
- So would you say
the answer to that
simply is parallel everything?
I mean, that's basically
where I'm coming to.
It's not a great answer.
Especially in America
because we are multicultural
in the best sense of it.
That was the purpose
of the country.
And they're using it
against us in a way.
But do you see a better
alternative than that?
That we'll just,
like-minded people will just
have different everything.
Schools, coffee shops.
- I don't think that's good.
- Yeah, I didn't say it's good.
But I'm just asking you
for a better alternative
for the future.
- That would be, I think
the undesirable alternative
that we would be routed
out of our own civilization
and then be forced like
the productive people
that we are to rebuild
from the rubble, right?
- Well, by the way, ours will
be much better in the end.
- Oh, yeah.
- For sure. For sure.
But there'll be a
lot of pain points.
- Which is why they declare
war on us. (laughter)
'Cause they literally will,
they'll see what we are
doing through virtue
and look at the vice that
they've been spreading and say,
okay, but we need some
of what you've got.
It's like, well,
you're not having it.
- That is one of my major
fears, that if Biden wins again,
or the Democrats are in charge,
that there will start
being a secession movement
that I think most likely,
even though I don't
want to give it energy,
it will probably be
somewhat just, right,
from let's say Florida,
Texas, Tennessee,
a couple other states.
And they'll be fine leaving.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- The other guys
are never gonna let,
the Cali's never gonna
let Florida walk.
- Nope.
- Without, you know.
- Who knows where that goes.
And I completely agree with you.
I don't like giving energy
by talking about the idea
of secession because no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
We have lost far too much
ground to the communists.
We need to start taking
some stuff back, right.
We need to start, why
aren't we on the attack?
You know, everything good
and just is in our
favor here, right?
Like, we are not the ones
who are doing terrible things
to children.
We are not the ones who
are ruining the economy.
We are not the ones
who are just...
You can see the quality
of their civilization
just degrading around them.
- Right their planes are
gonna fall out of the sky
because they're gonna
hire the wrong people.
And their doctors won't
be qualified, yeah.
- Exactly right.
That's exactly right.
The quality of their
civilization degrading,
things are gonna start failing.
How is it that we are losing
to these people, right?
And so basically we have to
essentially harden our hearts
and say, just know, you
are wrong on everything
and we're not gonna accept
your arguments on anything.
And people vote for
us 'cause we are right
and we can prove it.
We're right on morality.
We're right on economics. We're
right on practical matters.
We're right on just
everything that we're saying.
And they're wrong on everything.
You know, in fact, they're
not just wrong, they're evil.
They are actually evil
and they're trying
to ruin your life.
And that's how we need
to start framing it.
Sorry, look at
them. Look at 'em.
They're giving needles
to drug addicts.
What kind of maniacs are you?
You know, don't even talk about
what they're doing as children.
What kind of maniacs
are these people?
You know, they're
stealing your money.
And it's like, no,
I'm not having...
- Well soon enough they're gonna
literally be stealing your kids.
I dunno if you've heard what's
going on in California now.
If you you don't affirm.
If you don't affirm.
I mean, it's the
least affirming thing
you could possibly do.
- And they already
do this in Canada,
where it's like literally
the state can justify
stealing your children.
I mean, there'll probably
be a time in the future
where it'll be considered
wild that the state
can find reasons to take
your children away from you.
You know, if, when we win,
you know, the bond
between parent
and child will be
considered inviable. .
- So do you see it in a
weird way that in America,
that our federalism in a
bizarre way is a weakness too,
because a million
people fled Cali.
That's a million people who
probably would've fought
for a lot of those things,
myself included, right?
Big time campaigner
to get rid of Newsom.
But I'm here fortifying
this place now.
So the divide, because
of our federalism
will increase where,
as you were saying,
you guys kind of resurrected
your own Labor Party because...
- We've got nowhere to go.
- You've got nowhere to go.
- Yeah.
- That's an odd position
for us to be in I suppose.
- That's interesting as well.
'Cause also the states
give secessionism
a kind of life as well, right?
You want, that's an
option we could take.
It's like, yeah, but you
don't want that option.
You know, you don't want to
break up the United States.
What you want is
to defeat the left
and completely route them out
of all the
institutions, you know?
And so you've gotta start
really thinking about
how are we gonna do that?
You know, we need a
proper ground game.
We need to literally, you know,
take printouts of, look at what
is happening where they are,
look at what they're doing.
We are going to do
the opposite of this.
And you need to start
literally pulling people away
from them and being like,
no, they're bad people.
They are bad. What
they're doing is bad.
It is immoral.
They lie to you
about the morality
and they're going
to ruin this country
as they've ruined the states
they occupy at the moment.
And so you need to actually
start taking things back
from those, not enough
to just simply say,
okay, we'll just try
and get away from them.
Maybe it's morally neutral.
No, they're evil and
they have to be stopped.
- So let's spend
our last few minutes
discussing the Trump
DeSantis thing,
because I think you might offer
some interesting
insight on that.
You know, my position, here
in the free state of Florida,
I don't have to twist or contort
myself to defend DeSantis.
He happens to be
more conservative
than me on certain issues.
I was fine with the 15 week
abortion ban we had here.
He went for six.
But I can accept that he's the
chief executive of the state
with the super majority
and did, but okay, fine.
Everything else you
get all the good stuff.
I don't have to
repeat it to you.
Where do you sit on all of this?
- I hate it.
I hate the conflict. I
hate everything about it.
- Yeah, I do too.
I take no pleasure
in what I'm doing
when I have to criticize Trump.
- It drives me crazy, right?
Because like I said,
I've supported Santis
for a number of years now
because he was an
amazing governor,
and he still is an
amazing governor
and he's really led
the way in legislating
against left wing morality.
You know, I mean he's really
got a fantastic track record
of absolutely crushing
them and just increasing
his majority by going,
no, no, no, look,
we are right, they're wrong.
I'm good. They're bad.
And we're gonna do these things.
And look, and now, I mean,
what's it now like 65%
approval rating or something?
- Oh yeah. It's through.
- It's mad, right?
And so it's like,
okay, fantastic.
But there are also kind of
immutable laws of politics
that unfortunately I think
DeSantis has kind of failed to,
not predict, but failed
to observe right?
And that's, the first one is
from like Robert Green's books,
"The 48 Laws of Power",
which is never outshine
the master, right?
Trump is a more veteran
statesman than him
by virtue of being
A, the president and
being older, right?
Now, I am completely in
agreement with all those people
that say, look, do we have
to have such old people
as the presidential candidates?
I totally, totally agree,
but you are kind of
in that position.
And I think that
people understand
the world through stories.
And part of the reason
that I want it to be Trump.
And I think a lot of Trump
supporters feel this way.
'Cause I mean, you know,
whether you like it or not,
he's like 50 points up
in the polls, right?
So he is crushing it.
And I've got many
criticisms of the way Trump
conducts himself,
conducts his campaign.
And I think the reason none
of these criticisms land
is because actually
we're not in the realm
of political policymaking
and things like that
when we talk about this.
I think what's
happening to America
is a genuine spiritual crisis.
And I think actually
Trump is the only guy
who can kind of resolve
that spiritual crisis
because I think they
screwed him in 2020.
And I think Trump needs
to have his sort of
return of the king moment
where he comes back,
and it has to be Trump
because they hate him
more than anything and they
did this to him, right?
And that's why it
has to be Trump.
And this, I think his
base feels that way.
I think the average
sort of, you know,
middle American who's
just like, you know,
Trump will die, I
don't care, you know?
And I really, and I'm honestly,
I'm genuinely on
this train with them.
No, it's Trump because F them,
because F them that's why.
- You know, it's so interesting
because I'm with you
on so much of this,
and I think it's a spiritual
crisis and they screw,
they're in the process
of screwing him
in all these federal cases
and all of that stuff.
My criticism has
been, and I wonder,
I wanna know your
thoughts on this
because you obviously
care about truth
and you care about decency
and everything else.
I think had he not gone so
scorched earth with DeSantis
that I'd have an easier
time with this right now.
Like I just see the guy
that I think is the best,
that is the guy we've
been waiting for that
in any other year, we'd
be like, wait a minute,
we have a guy who did
everything we could have asked.
- Sorry to interrupt,
but that's it, isn't it?
In any other year,
right? That's the thing.
- So no, we may
not, in a weird way,
we almost don't deserve him.
I can sort of accept that.
- No, no, it, what it is
is just prudence, right?
It's like if I were DeSantis,
I would've been like,
I'm gonna go for it
just not yet, right?
'Cause Trump can only go for
it this last time, really.
'Cause otherwise
he'll be too old,
or we'll have two
presidential runs.
So he can't go for
a third, right?
So DeSantis is a
young man still.
He's about my age
actually, isn't he?
- I think he's 44 or 45.
- Yeah, I'm 44. Yeah.
So like, he should
have been like,
well, I'll just wait four years.
- Is the inherent problem also
that if Trump truly believes
that the election was stolen,
and clearly you believe,
at least to some extent,
that that is the case.
And by the way, millions,
tens of millions of people
do believe that, at
least at some level,
that why wouldn't they
just steal it again?
Has he done anything
to have them?
Like why hasn't he
brought that case forward?
I need to him to say that.
Well, here's what I'm gonna do,
so it doesn't happen
all over again.
- Yeah.
Did you read the
Time Magazine article
basically saying how we...
- Oh, fortified the election?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Was it Time, I think
it was the Atlantic?
- No, no, it was Time.
It was time. It was time.
- Yeah. We didn't, right.
There were systems
in place to fortify.
- They may as well have
just said it, right?
And it's like, okay.
But one thing that you can
take away from reading that,
because I read that in
with great interest,
was how much effort this
was for them, right?
There was a lot of effort.
And it was because they just
had four years of Trump,
four years of, you know,
orange Hitler destroying
the entire country
by making everyone wealthy
and happy and prosperous,
and ending a lot of
problems around the world
and making sure that
people respected America
as a superpower again.
That is unconscionable.
You can't have any
of that, right?
And so they felt
deeply oppressed.
And so they were
very, very motivated
to do the things
they did, right?
They were very
motivated to do it.
I'm not sure that same
energy is there this time
because they've had
four years of Biden
ruining everything for them.
And actually things were
tangibly better under Trump.
Everyone had more money,
things were going better,
people felt less...
- But you don't
think the elite class
is still feeling
pretty good right now?
- No, no, the elite,
I don't know. I dunno.
- Or whoever's pulling
the strings there.
- That's the thing.
Like, do they seem
like they're happy?
They seem afraid
to me, actually.
You know, usually with
any kind of elite class,
a sort of a cruel
exercise of power
is a sign of weakness
rather than strength.
Because it, you know,
you've got the power,
but you really
shouldn't be using it.
You should be able to persuade
those people underneath you
to do the things that
you think should be done,
because that shows you've
got moral legitimacy.
If you've got to literally like,
start crushing people
like they are now,
then it shows that
actually they're afraid
and they think they're
wiping out threats.
But whenever you do that,
anything that was connected
to what you just whacked
is like, oh, well
that wasn't good.
And, you know, you
keep doing that.
You create a larger, large
body of people who are just,
okay, you guys seem mad
and we're afraid
of you now, right?
And so it's just bad
blood, it's bad vibes,
it's negativity.
And so I'm not convinced that
the democratic elite class
actually feels good about
the position that they're in.
I mean, they must
know that Biden,
I mean, almost all Democrats
know that Biden's a terrible,
terrible candidate.
He's terrible president.
And what, we're gonna
really gonna go through
all this effort again
to get that guy back.
Do we want that guy actually,
you know, are we so wedded?
You know, 'cause we...
- Well, maybe it
won't be that guy.
That's a whole, that's
a whole other topic.
- Maybe, but either way,
it's the same agenda
as well, right?
And so I just, I
wonder how much of the,
sort of the pressure that,
'cause I mean, we haven't heard
about Trump for four years.
Like people forget.
It was nonstop
wall-to-wall media coverage
of how Nazi, you
know, a Cheetah Hitler
is doing this terrible thing.
He's tweeted this terrible
thing today, right?
- Meanwhile, all time
low black unemployment,
all time low Hispanic
unemployment.
- In reality, everything
was actually going great
for everyone.
There was light at
the end of the tunnel
for everyone, right?
Things were
genuinely going well.
And now I don't
think anyone can say
there's light at the end
of the tunnel, right?
I mean, look at the
price of everything.
You know, look how difficult
everything seems to be.
Look how much pressure
everyone seems to be under.
Like really, you've got
the energy to make sure
that the guy made everything
great is not coming back.
Like, I mean, I'm not
saying it can't happen.
I'm not saying it
won't happen, right?
You know, I definitely
think it happened in 2020,
but it was just very obvious
from the Time Magazine article
that this took a lot of work,
and you had to have the
people willing to do the work,
you know, to spend
all the energy.
'Cause I mean, they
got paid, but it still,
like you've gotta,
it's a loss of morale
that you have to have
to do this, right?
And I'm not sure
that's there this time.
And maybe it is,
maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe it'll be, maybe I'll
eat these words sort of thing.
But I'm not sure that
they've got the energy
for another fortification.
And honestly, I just really
think it has to be Trump.
I just, I really
wanted it to be Trump
that finally crushes them.
And then DeSantis would
be the perfect man
to step in and go, yep, okay,
we've routed them, we've got
the winning formula, right?
'Cause everyone, I mean,
there are so many
complaints about
Trump's first term, right?
And even Trump,
when he was on Tucker
Carlson, he was like,
well, I was kind of
naive about this.
You know, I didn't realize
all of the establishment
being against all
the institutions
would essentially lock arms
and keep me out, you know?
And maybe Trump in the
next administration
will legislate a lot harder
against his political opponents.
And in fact, after the mugshot,
maybe he definitely will.
But DeSantis would
be a brilliant guy
to come in after that and
go, look, we know what works.
We know how we're gonna win.
I've got a blueprint of it.
Trump's just done
whatever he's just done.
We know that we're
righteous and we're decent
and we're creating a
better world in what we do.
And there would be no
conflict whatsoever
'cause Trump could then just
go as the outgoing president,
DeSantis is our boy, he's on,
let's carry on the mega agenda
and let's carry on making
this country great.
Let's make the world great.
We've got this, you know,
but instead that fighting.
And it's just...
- It's so interesting though,
because you're making a more
com, what you just said,
which I actually agree
with almost all of it
is a more compelling case
than I think Trump
has made for himself.
- I know.
- I think actually you're,
well, clearly you're
far more eloquent
in the exp- in the decent
explanation of why it works,
where he's doing still the
name calling and the games.
And it's like, I know, I don't
want be part of that anymore.
That's what I'm saying.
You just made a case
that is completely decent
and also proves
that I have not lost
all of my classical
liberal beliefs,
because even though I'm
still a DeSantis guy,
I let you say it
right here on my show.
Could there be anything more
truly liberal than that?
- But that's the thing,
I'm a DeSantis guy.
I've been praising
on the podcast.
You know, every day we
do the podcast and then,
you know, every day
DeSantis will have done
something else great.
And we are just like,
brilliant DeSantis just
legislated against this
what they wanted.
They've taken an L, brilliant.
And again, and again and again.
And it's the, he shouldn't have
been challenging the master.
That's the problem.
'Cause you know, there is a
hierarchy of these things.
Trump was the president.
He's the guy that the story's
about at the moment, you know?
And then Trump needs to
come to the sort of natural
conclusion of his hero's
journey, defeat the villain,
and then ride off
into the sunset.
You know, go back to Florida
and, you know, have a,
go to dinner parties
and do whatever he wants.
And just instead, he's
sniping at DeSantis.
And I agree, you know,
he's not covering himself
in glory in this, you know,
but DeSantis is not
doing great in the polls
compared to Trump because I
think everyone feels this,
you know, in this sort of
genuine conservative way.
So, hang on a second. It's just
not your time yet, you know?
So I think whoever advised
DeSantis to go for it now,
I just think that
was a miscalculation.
You know, you're a young
man, you're a young man.
Keep making Florida amazing.
You know, get yourself
another five points
up in the approval
rating in Florida,
which I don't doubt
that he can do.
And it's only four years,
you are a young man,
you've got the time,
then you can do it.
And then everyone would
be behind DeSantis.
- As I have said many times,
if this all ends with
Trump as my president
and DeSantis as my governor,
I will be just fine with that.
- Well, yeah, that's
hardly a loss, is it?
- I will be justified with that.
Carl, it was a pleasure
seeing you again,
and I'm glad things
are going so well,
and I hope you make
it through America
without getting too
depressed, because...
- Well, I'm having a great time.
- You know, you're
in Florida, sorry.
- Well, yeah, I'm in Florida,
so I'm having a great time.
But no, I mean, everyone,
everyone is just so nice.
And I get to see loads
of people who I know
from the internet in real life,
and they're all lovely
and it's great to be here.
- The internet in real
life, how about it?
Good seeing you, man.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop screaming,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.